[Musique]
avec beau julien scheider ce matin
bonjour julien bonjour pauline ont parlé
dans le journal avec antoine fenaux joe
biden est donc à bruxelles depuis
quelques heures pour une journée très
intense une série de sommets
internationaux bien sûr lié à la guerre
oui joe biden est contraint c'est le mot
qui revient plusieurs fois la une de la
presse française pour désigner l'état
d'esprit dans lequel arrivent le
président américain pour quoi et bien
parce que depuis son arrivée à la maison
blanche le président bailly donne
focalise toute son attention sur la
chine n'est pas du tout sûr l'europe
sauf que rappelle le figaro la guerre en
ukraine a changé la donne mais ce
costume de guerre at il vraiment envie
de le mettre joe biden s'interroge le
journal les menaces de recours à l'armé
nucléaire par la russie sont prises très
au sérieux par washington joe biden doit
aussi rassurer ses partenaires européens
du bien fondé de l'alliance militaire de
l'otan et de son principe de solidarité
mutuelle en cas d'agression lacroix
écrit que l'amérique est de retour en
europe car elle n'a pas d'autre choix si
elle veut montrer sa crédibilité aux
yeux du monde et surtout aux yeux de la
chine avant l'invasion russe de
l'ukraine l'europe n'était pas
clairement la priorité des états unis
donc sauf qu'avec un risque d' escalade
militaire écrit le journal c'est un vrai
changement de doctrine qui est en train
de s'opérer enfin en toute ironie
libération dit presque merci à vladimir
poutine d'avoir je cite réinventer
l'occident l'union européenne si prompte
à se diviser écrit jean quatremer n'a
jamais été aussi unis alors qu'elle est
confrontée à une menace militaire
directe et ce sujet on y reviendra dans
le décryptage avec bilal tarab et dans
une dizaine de milles joe biden arrive
donc en europe julien avec un nouveau
train de sanctions à imposer à la russie
et un carnet de commandes en gaz qu'il
espère bien remplir effectivement c'est
l'autre enjeu de ces différents sommets
rappelle le washington post pallier le
manque de gaz russe pour les pays
européens qui en dépendent comme
l'allemagne ou les pays baltes
washington s'était déjà proposé il ya
quelques semaines et des discussions
vont être menées avec bruxelles pour
fournir l'europe en gaz naturel liquéfié
américains au moins pour les deux
prochains hivers sauf que ça implique
des investissements nécessaires pour
stocker ce type de gaz il ya aussi les
problèmes de coûts de production et de
transport mais l'oncle sam se dit prêt à
tout pour aider son allié européen et à
la sortir de la dépendance du gaz russe
et pendant ce temps moscou continue de
vouloir vendre son gaz aux européens
mais pas à n'importe quel prix ou pas
n'importe quel moines et surtout par
n'importe quelle monnaie car la russie
l'a bien compris l'enjeu et les
conséquences potentielles de cet arrêt
d'approvisionnement de l'europe en gaz
et bien ce pourrait être la chute du
cours de la monnaie russe du rouble le
wall street journal explique très bien
pour avoir du gaz moscou voudrait que
les ses clients en fait achète son gaz
non plus en dollars comme ça se fait
depuis des décennies mais en roubles
pour sauver ou pour tenter de sauver la
monnaie russe sauf que cette stratégie
selon le quotidien américain est à
double tranchant cela peut effectivement
sauver en partie la monnaie russe mais
cela peut surtout et c'est peut-être
plus probable provoqué une rupture
massive de contrat dans l'actualité en
france à présent en direction la corse
où les images à yvan colonna ce
nationaliste qui a été tué en prison et
qui est décédé ce qui était agressée en
prison et qui est décédé cette semaine
les hommages à yvan colonna ont suscité
la colère de l'état alors surtout un
type d'hommage en particulier donc le
contexte est que le corps de l'ancien
militant nationaliste est arrivé hier
soir à ajaccio sur l'île de corse est
depuis la collectivité régionale donc le
l'exécutif local a mis les drapeaux
corses en berne en signe de deuil pour
exprimer je cite le parisien une
tristesse collective plusieurs mairies
de l'île ont annoncé vouloir faire de
même sauf que vu de paris ça ne passe
pas du tout cette commémoration est une
faute je cite une chose est de respecter
la douleur d'une famille une autre est
de transformer un homme condamné pour
l'assassinât d'un préfet en martyr a
réagi l'ancien premier ministre manuel
valls le journal corse matin lui
s'intéresse plutôt aux habitants du
village de cargèse origine d'où est
originaire d'où était originaire yvan
colonna là bas on ne parle pas d'un
ancien condamné à perpétuité mais d'un
enfant du pays alors les habitants ne
minimise par son acte il préfère parler
de ses souvenirs de leurs souvenirs avec
yvan colonna de ce passionné de sport
qui aimait faire des footings autour du
village ce qui révolte les habitants et
aussi la partie de la population de
l'île et bien ce sont les circonstances
dans lesquelles est décédé yvan colonna
violemment agressé en crise on vous
l'avait dit parent un détenu a
radicalisé alors qu'il faisait tous les
deux du sport en salle une fois la
période de deuil terminé viendra le
temps politique écrit la croix les
militants de la cause indépendantiste
ont obtenu quelque chose que personne
n'avait obtenu en un demi siècle à
savoir l'ouverture de discussions sur
l'autonomie de l'île oui parce que tout
ça est un bien de bien sûr dans un
contexte particulier à moins de trois
semaines du premier tour de la
présidentielle oui marine le pen a
présenté hier son programme chiffré avec
un objectif principal tourner
définitivement la page du fiasco du
débat de 2017 face à emmanuel macron ce
qui la candidate du rassemblement
national semble bien parti pour accéder
une nouvelle fois second tour quel sera
son score final l'opinion se pose la
question et s'interrogent notamment sur
les dangers d'une appelons la comme ça
d'une non compagne d'une campagne au
rabais qui n'intéresse pas grand monde
où tout semble joué d'avancé et on a un
président sortant qui perd régulièrement
des points dans les sondages au profit
de sa rivale du rassemblement national
il y à un mois écrit d'éditorial de la
croix la guerre en ukraine accaparé tous
les esprits aujourd'hui l'ambiance a
changé et peut-être que le président
devrait penser à devenir ou redevenir
candidat avant le premier tour ce qui
est sûr et je terminerai avec ça c'est
que la soirée électorale du premier tour
ce ne sera plus tôt plus ou moins
inédites cette année elle sera court sur
france 3 et courte sur tf1 pour la
première chaîne de france il y aura une
heure de débat et puis s'en va pour
ensuite une rediffusion des visiteurs la
11e en six ans qu'en penser merci
beaucoup aux julien alors pour le coup
la soirée électorale sur france 24 ce
sera jusqu'à minuit au soir du premier
tour merci beaucoup julien on se
retrouve tout à l'heure dans paris
direct et nous on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes avec antoine penot pour
le journal de 7h30 à tout de suite